[Music]
and trolling backfired news you just go
inside what's going on there's random
little things flying around are those
little floaties controlling backfired
news submitted by Trent's from the Big D
well that Detroit Delaware I don't know
a man assaulted his wife after learning
she trolled his YouTube video for six
months oh well she
how does she troll her she in the
background showing titty without anyone
noticing hi in the comments be like you
suck stop doing this shaker all to
understand the truth have you done that
to Nikki's channel I've done the
opposite with positive comments with
your channel or you make a fake no no no
don't say that now she's gonna think all
positive comments are from Union Japan
oh oh
and so this 44 year old man that's
[ __ ] up he's all prideful and shins
like finally living his passion and his
wife's life I can get off you piece of
[ __ ] what that means the wife has a good
sense of humor did she do it maliciously
or no cuz if you did that to me and I
found out six months later I would be so
happy
Oh continue to shut down your channel
and I'm like starting areas cuz you're
my wife and you love me and then I'm
like oh that's funny I would've never
but I'm serious I only want you to shut
it down
Oh with the seriously they're saying
that his 36 year old wife has been
sabotaging his attempts to become a
youtuber oh my dears been seeing several
offensive and negative comments such as
idiot and Baldy yeah so he's getting it
from both ends in real life she's like
you suck don't do this [ __ ] and then
she's going on the computer she's
anonymously going you sucks I'll do this
she was doing a person but I think it's
I bet shots of aggressive I don't think
she was because once he found out that
it was his wife that had been leaving
these comments that's when he it's
[ __ ] up but he like kicked her in the
face oh my god
cause injuries that lasted up to a month
yep her injuries lasted in his heart
forever double karate kicked her shoes
so he found out that she had
acquaintances to leave offensive
comments she's a troll team and so once
he found out he bound his wife's arms
and legs oh where does he have a [ __ ]
rope with whenever he finds the chest
tape is what they report holy [ __ ]
that's sick and twisted yeah so then
that's like duct tape no probably bubble
tape al [ __ ] crap you've got [ __ ]
watched a pitcher double-sided tape you
just put right here anything a t-shirt
inside people I'm not titled with an
iron once iron the cord is that long it
was it consensual oh yeah with you I
figured there was a 90% chance it was
consensual
oh for sure yeah part though oh just
come in the court it's long enough most
courts are like very and they're heavy
you wasn't trying to get out Steve I see
yeah I wasn't trying to get out I was
talking you know what's pretty long a
vacuum cleaners cord yeah it's big oh
that is how we use nah I don't wanna
hurt you orange Joe seems like the guy
who ties himself up so that he could
like get off in some weird way it ties
himself up me watch the pornos yeah yeah
I got a button with my nose at you so
you [ __ ] her up dude yeah [ __ ]
psycho dude so the rest of this article
is they just put in comments of people
that heard this story so then she's
afraid of them that's why she wants to
destroy him but she can't hate it she
just panda reviews and [ __ ] this is why
when people say words or violence I'm
like no no violence is violence [ __ ]
your wife clowning on you and telling
you you suck in all this [ __ ] isn't does
not justify drop-kicking or what
the first plan of action is to direct
kick in the face that's hard that's I
mean I don't like it but that's just
crazy to me those are just all kinds of
stereotypes so coming to only if the
form is good
see that's what that's the problems
you're imagining the perfect kick oh my
god
I just picture like how do you reach
down listen I just pictured them biting
and then he just launches this [ __ ]
high kick and I'm like damn in case you
guys were wondering what kind of videos
he was posting he was ASMR highlighting
some of the city of us restaurants in
sight so he's a [ __ ] lifestyle
vlogger again we are gonna get our wings
today no he thinks that she was
sabotaging it when it's like negative
comments are just a thing with YouTube
and that's not what sabotages what he's
always reading it like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] hates me and then he's like
confiding in his wife about that [ __ ]
and she's like oh that's so he's like
well at least they didn't mention my
bald head oh yeah what she did was bad
but she deserved that no one deserves
that at least he got comments I can't
get any on my video looks like baldies
going to prison thank God
I bet all those comments are his wife
baldies going to present out yeah he
logged onto her computer ICC account on
and he's like you're the [ __ ] troll
yeah for six years six years of law
dedication all years oh my man you're
tickling month Oh since mutt no you said
it no you said you said you said years
that was about it sighs I'm the one that
should highlight it I want to be right
sabotaging his attempts to become a
youtuber oh here's this is what a
relationship
argument looks like 44 year old man 36
year old that's when I said here dude
this lady's the one who should've been
posting videos this lady's funny all
your husband's great today watching his
video we're gonna be typing I wouldn't
call Baldy calm all [ __ ] prosecutors are
requesting a three-year prison sentence
that's kind of short for domestic abuse
but aren't Japanese jails whose told me
that they're all [ __ ] up uh if you're
in death death row but I wouldn't be
surprised though because I played this
game called Yakuza and in their jail
it's pretty there's some Psychopaths
that bully each other really hard I'm
surprised you played a game period oh I
saw a walkthrough sorry does Japanese
jails have paper doors though they're
water far away from it just in case
my friend was in jail in Japan for two
weeks and he said it wasn't that bad the
food was actually good two weeks you can
see what they're fed because I forgot it
those bias or something they did a video
on that's pretty good Japanese jail food
they [ __ ] good they get grilled fish
and it's like nutritious food and
[ __ ] on my soup yeah I want to go to
jail Japan right Oh a magic but yeah you
think that and then they just leave it
outside and they can't touch anything on
our prison system is that Death Row's
actually kind of nice oh they treat you
better right so then some guys who are
in like you know maximum-security and
[ __ ] they try to get on death row just
to get treated better because they
already feel like they're far if you're
gonna spend life might as well just
[ __ ] get death roll that's how they
feel
yeah but most crimes in Japan right now
are happening from senior citizens
because Brahmans right because they'd
rather be in jail verse and being taken
care of then out and out and having to
work and doing stuff yeah it's not
enough because they're facing the same
problem we are with the baby boomer
generation and all that there's not
enough young people to afford so they're
they're like I guess their retirement
money or the
security just shrank like crazy so yeah
there it's like Korea has a big problem
one two three different swear it's like
one young person - like three old people
or some [ __ ] so all I do is print money
other than that let's hold everything
they don't have a fiat economy like us
yeah so the more comments Baldy has a
short fuse I've come to learn that
anyone who identifies himself as a
youtuber should be dealt with very
delicately they tend to be live wires
can we see this [ __ ] no I don't have
one of his channels to love no so the
people writing this article so that they
couldn't find any of his videos
well he's not [ __ ] using SEO as
properly hmm yep I just sharing anything
come on now calm down
because of all this maybe his wife was
just giving him honest feedback - idiot
oh maybe he's missing you never know I
try not to look at all haters like oh
I'm just getting hated on yeah when he
was in there he well he met a bunch of
like there was some young koozies like
they're really nice and the food was
really nice too but he was stuck out
there because the American ambassador
wouldn't let him speak to the American
Embassy or some [ __ ] for a while damn
but I want to go in there just hang out
and eat the food you just eat Japanese
food not like Japanese prison food
that's authentic experience she wants a
bento box lit underneath the door I want
a [ __ ] tattooed guy staring at me in
the claw me that happens already in jail
there there's there's probably is but
yeah I don't know anything about that oh
yeah I know women's jail well women were
perfect sure this is true we never do
anything wrong women don't really commit
crimes though no dick they get away with
more crimes as would you I'd break
hearts yeah [ __ ] yeah let it out bud
it's all right baby that's in the past
they commit lawless crimes
now they call crimes of the heart there
you go
[Music]